médaille d'argent ce matin pour la
france en basket les bleus battus par
les etats-unis cet après-midi les
français handball affronte le danemark
en finale et les volleyeurs tricolores
défi en finale également les joueurs du
comité olympique russe et non la russie
exclut des jeux de tokyo
la correspondance à moscou de verre à
kaufmann verra le comité olympique russe
est cinquième au tableau des médailles
aux jeux de tokyo ce qui déplaît à une
partie de la presse mondiale vladimir
poutine s'est exprimé à ce sujet verra
bonjour grigori elle la décision du
tribunal arbitral du sport d'exclure la
russie des grandes compétitions
internationales est politiquement
motivée a déclaré vladimir poutine
selon lui les performances des athlètes
russes prouve de la meilleure façon que
toutes les tentatives de politiser le
sport sont pathétiques insensée voire
nuisible à jour propose d'écouter
non je te conseille sanguine soit
guitare d'alstom est riche et les battre
partout sur les quais bus n'était pas
nier limites collectives quoi en ce qui
concerne l'hymne le drapeau et ainsi de
suite
je pense que la décision du tribunal
arbitral du sport et dans une certaine
mesure motivées politiquement
pourquoi parce que lorsque nous parlons
de dopage
tel a été toujours la pratique mondiale
il s'agissait toujours d'un athlète ou
de son entraîneur en particulier et l'on
déterminer son degré de culpabilité la
culpabilité est toujours individuelle et
bien que de nombreux pays
tous les pays soient confrontés au
dopage dans cette situation il me semble
que les responsables sportifs n'ont pas
pu résister aux assauts de la pression
politique mais d'un autre côté cela
n'affecte pas la qualité des
performances de nos athlètes leurs
performances prouvent de la meilleure
façon que toutes les tentatives de
politiser le sport sont pathétiques
insensée voire nuisible bruccio mon bac
à papier et
un peu une règle mais je rappelle que la
russie a été exclu en décembre 2020 pour
deux ans des grandes compétitions
internationales en cause des accusations
de dopage d'état contesté par les
autorités russes qui ont toujours clamé
le caractère individuel des de ces cas
de deux pages vers vadimir poutine a
également évoqué l'absence de l'hymne
national russe lors de cette quinzaine
olympique au japon tout à fait comme
vous l'avez certainement pu remarquer
ligne russe n'est pas joué lors des jo
de tokyo à la place vous pouvez entendre
le concerto pour piano numéro 1 de petr
cech ans qui célèbre compositeur russe
pour vladimir poutine donc si le comité
international olympique a préfère la
musique de tchaïkovski à celle
d'alexandre roy auteur de l'hymne
national c'est leur choix
écoutez magori la sauce sur l'accise qu
à foix gbagbo
ce match nous parlons de l'absence du
drapeau russe
oui cela aurait été mieux s'il y était
mais comme on peut le voir nos athlètes
ont un badge du comité olympique russe
avec le drapeau tricolore russe dessus
et alors est ce qu'il préfère la musique
de tchaïkovski à celle d'alexandre off
je ne sais pas s'ils écoutent la musique
de tchaïkovski mais bien sûr je le
répète une fois de plus à mon avis cette
décision est clairement motivée par des
considérations politiques
quant à l'avenir ces restrictions
s'appliquent jusqu'à la fin de l'année
je pense qu'à partir de ce moment là
toutes les tentatives de limiter ou
d'importuner la russie dans le domaine
sportif prendront fin d'une manière ou
d'une autre et si un poteau et capteurs
agréé niché aux téléacteurs où je suis
plutôt réussi les mises sur un fichier
au russe qui prendront fin le 16
décembre 2022 inclut les jo de tokyo il
est jo d'hiver de pékin en 2022 mais pas
ceux de paris en 2024
merci verhaeghe hoffman pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de moscou